right um I want to prove this this is
where I want to end up okay this is
where I want to finish but in order to
get there like that's my loss line I
need to start with something that I know
to be true and I don't know that this is
true yet okay but what I can do is I can
say well if I take something that I know
based on a and B which beyond the shy
over that is true then I'll use that as
my starting point and off I go all right
so here's what I'm going to do I'm gonna
say look I want something to be greater
than something else and I see a square
root in there okay see a square root so
this is something you're gonna get more
and more used to as you meet
inequalities more frequently next to you
okay
but when I see a square root and I see
an inequality I think squares right the
reason I think of squares is because if
you take any number n right positive
negative zero and you square it right
doesn't matter what any is you're going
to get something greater than or equal
to zero do you agree with that so this
is kind of like a so long as n is a real
number then I can I can say that this is
true all right so I'm gonna take that as
my basis but I'm gonna take a particular
value of n namely
cross my fingers and see how I go okay
okay now when I have a go at this right
this is true because this is true right
a and B both real numbers
therefore a take away B is also a real
number
okay so I'm just going to chuck that
okay now so what you're saying okay well
I can use this to get from here to here
all right I've got a minus B I want to
get torn a plus B and somehow an a B is
going to appear it's not too hard to get
an AV out of this right what could I do
to that left-hand size expanded okay now
so far nothing to ground-breaking has
taken place yet okay but that's a wrap
we're almost there I've got an a B it's
over the other side of this inequality
you see that okay so how can I get
something useful over the other side hmm
now I could add I could add to a bit
that'll be fun if I'll just pick the
back don't write it but I could write a
squared plus B squared B okay
that kind of looks a bit closing cuz
you're like oh like I could take that I
could divide by to it right that that
would be cool cuz then I have it / -
over there and I could do some square
root business but then then you're kind
of stuck do you notice you're stuck okay
because once I get my square root over
here you put this square root over here
and you have two problems right can you
see what the two problems are problem
number one I don't want a scrap of this
bed I want a and B problem number two I
am I don't have a two down the bottom I
actually have a root two right so it's
like whoo okay that's not quite what I
wanted not a bad idea though another
suggestion
for a beat okay now our first suggestion
was to add you maybe and we saw it hit a
dead end
no problem what else can we try I'm
going to add for a bit
okay now why would you add before a B
that's not obvious but what I'm actually
doing we have a name for this rights how
we got the quadratic formula I'm
completing this square okay that's what
I'm doing over here now it's a bit
unusual because it's already a square
but I'm going to make it a different
square right watch let's add for a B to
both sides from you know when I had for
a B to this it'll become not - but okay
now if I've added for a B they're over
the other side or happy times okay now
you're starting to see this is a much
more promising Avenue than this one this
one here the brick wall oh well that's
okay but now over here what am I going
to do to this left-hand side I and I can
factorize I can factorize and of course
we ought to expect this kind of
factorization because we know where we
want ahead right a plus B all screaming
and that's greater than equal to now I
could write that for I be over there but
being that I want a fraction
I want that two over there I might as
well just anyone here to buy through are
you comfortable with that so I'm going
to end up with maybe over there and that
means now something which I'm just going
to because we're so close to a so course
I'm not going to be too formal with it
when we get into inequalities there's a
whole topic I'll deal with it in more
detail you've got to be really careful
with inequalities right we all know any
node here multiplied by a negative you
can't just multiply by negative numbers
it changes what's going on right in the
same way be careful with square roots
square roots are dangerous things for
the same reason that minus signs are
dangerous things it mucks about
sometimes with what's going on here okay
but suffice it to say for now because a
and B are both real numbers
I take Square to the side I can take the
square root of the side and the
inequality is preserved like this in
fact I'm just there I don't need to say
anything else that's the square root of
both sides now just to confirm right how
did I on what basis did I go from here
to here it's not difficult to think of
how this is gonna work
if all you're working with is real
numbers if I say 25 is greater than or
equal to 9 have these two walls last I
checked right I can take the square root
of both sides and it's still true it's
all good okay so being that that's case
I can apply some what kind of logic here
I'll prove it more formally a bit later
on but it's all I need to demonstrate
with no appeal to geometry anything like
that
there's our familiar old a MGM
inequality